I am really excited to be the first
person to show you our new news up it's
right here on the home screen the first
thing News wants to do is get a sense of
what I like so it's gonna give me a
short list of really great choices to
choose from and you'll see as I tap
additional recommendations come in on
the bottom to give you even more choices
so I read Atlantic wired New York Times
and ESPN I'm still with you warriors and
daring fireball topics too like science
baking and travel I could keep going but
I think that's a great start so I'll tap
Done News creates a personalized feed
called for you it's based on the choices
I just made and it's all my news in one
place you can see it looked great it's
easy to scan and it updates every time I
check news the articles can come from
anywhere but the best ones are built in
our new Apple news format it's straight
for newspapers - this is a New York
Times article and it looks like a New
York Times article
swipe down there's a photo gallery right
inline fast fluid to swipe through
in addition data and stats are part of
what's fun about sports so of course
which infographics can be part of it I'm
gonna swipe back - for you now news is
smart so the more I read the better it
gets it's showing me stories I'm
interested in but what if I want to
discover something new well I can tap
here in the bottom on explore and
explore based on what I've read will
show me new publisher channels I might
be interested in and suggested topics
but news keeps track of more than a
million topics so I can be much more
specific about my interests that is a
really quick look at news we can't wait
to get it in your hands thank you very
much